what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking thrones today I want to
talk about Daenerys Targaryen and Jon
Snow's relationship and what this might
mean for the beloved mother of dragons
the Game of Thrones community has been
buzzing about this relationship
especially now that Daenerys and John
have consummated their relationship but
what I want to ask all of you is do you
think this decision may have sealed
Danny's fate ever since season 1
Daenerys has assumed that she would
never have children other than her
dragons but I think it's safe to say
that in season seven they gave us more
than enough clues foreshadowing Daenerys
getting pregnant again I think there was
at least four references to the Narus
not being able to get pregnant in the
last two episodes alone they even gave
us some foreshadowing with John to when
he was out beyond the wall in the sixth
episode when John tried to give Longclaw
to Jorah Mormont he handed it back and
told John that it would serve him well
and his children after I think we can
all agree that John will get Daenerys
pregnant but this is where things
obviously can get a little bit
complicated
the most obvious clues of all was when
Daenerys and John had their own
conversation in the dragon pit and pay
very close attention to everything in
this video clip
you're not like everyone else
and your family hasn't seen its end
you're still here I can't have children
who told you that there weren't you
murdered my husband
has it occurred to you she might not
have been a reliable source of
information John might as well have just
broke down the fourth wall right there
and look straight into the camera and
said hey I'm gonna get her pregnant on
the Love Boat
but all kidding aside though I think
that scene was very telling in fact I
believe that 30-second clip I just
showed you was one of the most important
pieces of foreshadowing in this entire
series that scene right there may have
just set up the endgame with John and
Daenerys like I mentioned in my finale
breakdown video when you see Daenerys
hand John the baby dragon skull I think
that was symbolic and it means tenaris
will give John a child but what is
interesting about what Jorah Mormont
said to John was he told him Longclaw
would serve him well in his children
after which implies John would have more
than just one child
so perhaps Daenerys gets pregnant with
twins or possibly even triplets since
the dragon has three heads when Daenerys
hands John the piece of dragon skull
john tells her that her family hasn't
seen its end because she is still here
John is telling her that at least she is
still around to carry on the Targaryen
name but as we all know John is a
legitimate Targaryen - but the way John
said that has me feeling like Daenerys
might not always be here as we get
closer and closer to the end of the
series they have hinted at Daenerys not
surviving the series I think there is a
very good chance Daenerys might not make
it until the end even Tyrion was
reminding her that she needed a
successor in case she isn't around
anymore
someone who could ensure that the wheel
stays broken all of these Clues could be
leading us to this bittersweet ending
Daenerys has spent years and years
working towards ruling the Seven
Kingdoms we have seen her go through so
much during this journey and now she is
finally in Westeros with three large
dragons in a massive army yet she still
hasn't secured her position as the ruler
and that day may never come at least not
for her this was hinted at all the way
back in season two when Daenerys had her
vision at the house of the undying she
walked into the Great Hall of the red
keep in the iron throne was covered in
snow which was also a symbolic mean
John Snow aka Aegon Targaryen is the
rightful heir to the Iron Throne and not
her she didn't even get to touch the
throne in her vision and I don't believe
she ever will in her real life either in
this story history always tends to
repeat itself - and Jon Snow's mother
Leon a stark did not survive after she
gave birth to Jon Snow and the same
thing happened to Daenerys Targaryen 's
mother it's pretty interesting that the
same thing happened to both of their
mothers and now that these two are about
to have a child together perhaps the
same exact thing could happen to
Daenerys - I know I'm not the only one
who feels this way also I have seen some
other people say Daenerys might not
survive as well and after you start to
look at everything it definitely feels
like they could go in this direction
this does seem like the kind of ending
we could get with Game of Thrones after
Daenerys has spent all of this time and
sacrificed so much to get the Westeros
and will the Seven Kingdoms but in the
end she never actually does there is
another old prophecy that may reveal the
fate of Daenerys Targaryen and I have
talked about this before in another
video but that was before season 7 had
aired and now there is more evidence
leaning towards dawn and Canaris getting
married back in season 1 John and Sam
were asking each other if they had ever
slept with anyone and this is when John
tell Sam the story about the time he
could have slept with Raw's but he
didn't because he was afraid he would
bring a bastard child into this world
John did not want to be responsible for
a child having to grow up as a bastard
and this is why John said he had never
slept with Raw's but of course a few
seasons later he hooked up with eager in
anyway but she did not get pregnant
since I believe John will get Daenerys
pregnant I also believe when he finds
out he will want to marry Daenerys but
he could also marry her for political
reasons - and if that happens this would
make Daenerys his wife and the reason
why I say wife is because of the legend
of azor Ahai there are many theories out
there that state Daenerys is actually
niece Aneesa the wife of azor Ahai and
in case you want to familiar with this
I'm just gonna read to you the brief
summary of this old legend thousands of
years ago when darkness laid over the
world a hero azor Ahai was chosen to
fight against it to fight the darkness
azor Ahai needed to forge a hero's sword
so he labored for 30 days and 30 nights
until it was done however when he went
to temperate in water the sword broke
but he did not give up easily so he
started over and the second time he took
50
and fifty nights to make the sword even
better than the first time so when he
went to temperate again instead of doing
it in water he captured a lion instead
and drove the sword into its heart but
once again the steel shattered so the
third time when he went to temper the
sword he worked for a hundred days and
nights until it was finished but this
time he called for his wife Nissa Nissa
and he asked her to bear her breasts he
drove his sword into her living heart
with her soul combining with the steel
of the sword creating Lightbringer the
red sword of the heroes now personally I
don't think they're gonna do this in a
television show but they are putting
Daenerys in position of becoming John's
wife so who knows but I figured I would
mention this anyway because a lot of
people do stain behind this theory but
in my opinion I'm leaning towards what I
said in the beginning of this video
Daenerys Targaryen may see the same fate
of her own mother and Jon Snow's mother
but what do you all think about this the
main reason I wanted to make this quick
video was because I was curious to see
what the majority of you thought about
it I know some of you have commented
about this already but now I can see
what a larger portion of the fanbase
thinks so please put your comments down
below I have to thank all of you for
coming back once again to watch another
video I wasn't sure how many people
would continue watching now that the
season was over but all of you are such
strong supporters you continue to
surprise me every day and I cannot thank
you enough for that especially to
everyone on patreon I really appreciate
everything that you have contributed to
this channel I hope everybody has a
great day I will see you down in the
comment section bye
you
you